«Ich ging als Au-Pair nach New York ...
... und wohnte da bei einer Familie.
Dort lernten wir uns über Facebook kennen.»
«Das erste Date hatten wir in einem Drive-in-Kino.»
«Wir sprachen kein Wort während des Films.
Ich war schüchtern und nervös ...
... und ihr ging es ebenso.
Für mich war es speziell.
Ich hatte noch nie eine Frau aus
dem Ausland getroffen, ...
... die so viele Sprachen spricht.
Also war ich total nervös.
Ich wollte nichts Falsches sagen oder aufdringlich wirken.
Ich versuchte mich zu entspannen und hoffte,
sie würde etwas reden.
Aber offensichtlich war sie auch
schüchtern und nervös.
So sprachen wir dann kaum.»
«Es war sehr schwierig.
Wir waren uns gewohnt,
uns jeden Tag zu sehen ...
... und die Zeitdifferenz machte es
auch schwierig.
Das war wirklich hart.
Mit Skype und Facetime mussten wir immer
die richtige Zeit finden zum Reden.»
«Ich wohnte noch bei den Eltern
und sie sagten, ...
... wenn er mich
in der Schweiz besuchen kommt, ...
... müsste ich zuhause ausziehen und mir
eine eigene Wohnung suchen.
Sie kannten ihn noch nicht und wollten nicht,
dass er zwei Wochen bei ihnen wohnt.
Also suchte ich eine Wohnung
und zog zuhause aus.
Ich ging dieses Risiko ein, weil ich überzeugt war,
dass es ihm hier gefallen wird.
Also kam er mich besuchen.
Wir hatten einen Retour-Flug gebucht
für zwei Wochen Aufenthalt ...
... und schliesslich ging er nie mehr zurück.»
«Als ich hier ankam, hatte ich einen
totalen Kulturschock.
Woran ich mich erinnere, ist:
Es war so sauber.
Und alles war so gut organisiert.
Auswärts sprach niemand laut.
Zum Beispiel in einem Zug: Alle schweigen!
Es ist das Gegenteil von New York.
Ich war vorher noch nie in Europa ...
... und ich hatte keine Erwartungen.
Als ich dann kam, war ihre Familie sehr offen ...
... und nett und sie akzeptierten mich.
Das machte es einfacher, hier zu bleiben.»
«Am Anfang war es ein grosses Problem.
Heute ist Englisch unsere Haussprache.
Die Kinder wachsen Englisch, Deutsch und Italienisch auf.»
«Am Anfang war ich total fleissig.
Ich nahm einen Intensivkurs.
Fünf Tage die Woche ...
... jeden Tag sechs Stunden.
Ich erinnere mich.
Wir lernten den ganzen Tag Hochdeutsch.
Lesen, Schreiben und mit Kollegen sprechen, ...
... und wenn du dort raus kommst,
verstehst du kein Wort, ...
... weil sie Schweizerdeutsch reden!»